ANY OF THESE PARENTS WHEN THEY
MIGHT BE SENTENCED.
>> Sean: TRACE GALLAGHER IN
THE NEWSROOM TONIGHT, THANK YOU
AND ALSO TONIGHT OVER THE
WEEKEND, A TOWN HALL IN BERLIN
IN GERMANY, FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA SAID HE
WAS CONCERNED THAT PROGRESSIVES
ARE RISKING GOING AFTER EACH
OTHER IN A BRUTAL PRIMARY AND
WHAT HE CALLED "CIRCULAR FIRING
SQUAD."
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAS NOT A
FAVORITE TOPIC.
AN EXAMINER COME OBAMA REFERRED
TO HIMSELF ALMOST 400 TIMES DURN
TO HIMSELF ALMOST 400 TIMES DURG
THIS ONE SPEECH.
HERE IS JUST A FEW EXAMPLES, BUT
FOR THE BENEFIT OF TIME, WE
CAN'T GIVE UP THE WHOLE SHOW TO
HIM REFERRING TO HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PROBABLY THE BIGGEST IMPACT I
COULD HAVE COME I WAS ALSO
CONVINCED OF -- THERE'S ONLY ONE
CONVINCED OF -- THERE'S ONLY ONO
CONVINCED OF -- THERE'S ONLY ONF
ME.
I KNOW WHAT I CAN BELIEVE, I'M
NOT HERE TO SUPPORT ANY
POLITICAL PARTY.
I'VE HELD MY LAST POLITICAL
OFFICE, BUT I'M DEEPLY INVESTED.
I'M ASSUMING.
I ALWAYS USED TO SAY I THINK YOU
CAN.
ACTUALLY, I'M NOT SURE, MEYER
CORRECT ABOUT THAT?
I WANT, I WAS ELECTED BUT I CAN
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF IT.
HAVE BEEN ON BOTH SIDES AND I
WAS THE FIRST, I WOULD LIKE, I'M
NOT GONNA COME I KNOW FROM
EXPERIENCE.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO DO.
>> I DID NOT READ.
EVEN AS PRESIDENT --
I WAS PRETTY BUSY GUY.
>> Sean: TOBY KEITH, ALL ABOUT
ME, ALL ABOUT ART, ALL ABOUT
ONE, WHAT I WANT, WHAT I KNOW,
WHAT I WANT WHAT I SEE.
I LIKE TO TALK ABOUT YOU USUALLY
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE BUT I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT ME.
YOUR REACTION, THE PODCAST
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
CONTRIBUTOR NEWT GINGRICH, GOOD
TO SEE YOU BUT I WANT TO START
WITH AND I SEE YOU SMILING.
I WANT TO START WITH THIS PARTY.
AND THE LIST I GAVE KEVIN
McCARTHY, STACKED THE
SUPREME COURT, GET RID OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE FROM ABORTION
DURING LABOR AND AFTER LABOR, I
MEAN, THEN THE NEW GREEN DEAL.
YOU GET IT.
>> Newt: WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I
THINK WE SHOULD REMEMBER THAT I,
ME, I, ME PRESIDENT THE COLLAPSE
OF HIS OWN PARTY.
THEY LOST MORE SEATS IN
GOVERNMENT SHIPS AND CONTROLLED
THE U.S. HOUSE AND SENATE.
AND IN A SENSE BECAUSE IN THE
END, BARACK OBAMA LOVED
BARACK OBAMA BUT THE COUNTRY
SORT OF WANTED SOMEONE WHO
ACTUALLY DELIVERED SOMETHING.
AND SO LITERALLY COMING TO
PRESIDED OVER THE BIGGEST
COLLAPSE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IN MODERN TIMES BUT BECAUSE OF
THE NEWS MEDIA, OF COURSE SHE
WOULD NEVER QUITE KNOW THAT.
I THINK THE MOST REVEALING THING
IS WHAT IS HAPPENING ON THIS
WHOLE IDEA OF REPARATIONS.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY, AND IN A VERY
POSITIVE WAY TO ALLOW THE
DEMOCRATS TO EXPLAIN.
WHO WOULD EXACTLY GET
REPARATIONS?
HOW WOULD THEY DETERMINE AND HOW
FAR BACK WOULD YOU GO, YOU KNOW
COME UP WITH ELIZABETH BE
ELIGIBLE FOR ONE 1,302ND PART?
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, SOMEONE
VIRTUALLY OUT OF TOUCH WITH
REALITY TO BELIEVE IN THIS
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPLEX SOCIETY
WHICH CONTINUES TO THIS DAY TO
GET MASS MIGRATION HOLD ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
LEGAL GRATIAN, BY THE WAY THAT
YOU CAN SOMEHOW REACH OUT
MAGICALLY AND WHO TO GIVE
REPARATIONS TO.
THIS IS A PERFECT AL SHARPTON,
UTTERLY PHONY ISSUE, BUT IT
TELLS YOU THE DECAY OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE NOW HAS PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES WILLING TO GO SEE HIM
TO TELL HIM THEY WOULD SIGN A
BILL THAT IS CRAZY.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU.
YOU SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER.
ONE OF THE REASONS I BELIEVE IT
IS HAPPENING AT THIS TIME AT
THIS LEVEL IS BECAUSE THEY KNOW
IF THEY GET IN THE COUNTRY, ONCE
THEY ARE HERE, THEY ARE NOT
GETTING THROWN OUT.
WE HAD A POLL EARLIER TONIGHT.
BUT ALSO IT IS INTERESTING WHILE
EVERYBODY ARGUING ABOUT THE
BORDER.
THE PRESIDENT PREPARING AND
BUILDING THE WALL.
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO OVERRIDE
HIS VETO.
THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT ALLOCATED
AND IDENTIFIED $9 BILLION TO
COMPLETE THE WALL.
AND I THINK THE PEOPLE COMING
KNOW THAT THIS IS PROBABLY THEIR
LAST SHOT.
>> Newt: I THINK THAT IS PART
OF IT BUT I THINK THE OTHER PART
YOU TOUCHED ON A MINUTE AGO.
THE PRESIDENT IN ORDER TO GIVE A
SPEECH IN WHICH HE GOES TO EVERY
SINGLE FEDERAL COURT DECISION
THAT HAS CRIPPLED THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND DEALING WITH
IMMIGRATION.
AND THEN HE SHOULD ANNOUNCE THAT
ON BEHALF OF FAIRNESS, WE ARE
GOING TO OPEN UP CENTERS NEXT TO
THE JUDGE'S PERSONAL HOMES.
WE WILL BE GLAD TO SHARE AS MANY
PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE ILLEGALLY
AS THEY WOULD LIKE.
IN SOME OF THOSE COME I'M SURE
SOME OF THE NINTH CIRCUIT COURT
JUDGES WOULD BE THRILLED TO HAVE
500 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THE
HOUSE NEXT TO HIM.
BUT THIS WHOLE IDEA OF THE
JUDGES WHO COULD PROVE --
PRECIOUSLY EXERCISE LIBERALISM
AT NO COST, NO COST TO THEM
PERSONALLY AND NO CAUSE
PROFESSIONALLY AND I THINK THE
PRESIDENT OUGHT TO TAKE THAT
HEAD ON.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION REAL
QUICK AND WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME.
YOU ARE CONCERNED CHINA THEIR 5G
EXPANSION, FALLING BEHIND.
>> Newt: THE DEFENSE
INNOVATION BOARD JUST COME OUT
AND SAID, WE ARE LOSING BADLY
AND MAYBE THE FIRST DEFEAT IN
OUR COMPETITION WITH CHINA.
IF THEY CREATE CHINESE INTERNET
WORLDWIDE, WE ARE IN VERY DEEP
TROUBLE.
>> Sean: WE BETTER ALSO, WE
BETTER FIGURE OUT THE PENCILS
FOR ALL THE HACKING THAT GOES ON
AGAINST OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
GOVERNMENT.
APPARENTLY, WE KEEP ALLOWING